tell us about singing in the bathtub
this is a this is these are performances
that are meant for children as well yes
its first Sony wonder music that came to
me their whole thing is great music for
kids that parents can actually endure if
not enjoy and actually this is a
fantastic album we put together a whole
bunch of songs almost all of them from
40 and 50 years ago great old novelty
songs kind of thing Danny Kaye and Cab
Calloway used to sing gave them these
fabulous swing arrangements great music
producer Jay wending did it with me in
and voila
I'm a recording artist now what we
wanted to do tonight obviously was have
you sing one of these songs for a group
of children we don't we couldn't get a
group of children so you John is now
gonna sing these songs we have we have
some crew members here these guys are
all Union and you can do this for them
delight it
hi entertain children of all ages hi
kids I said hi kids
that's better I had a rooster and the
rooster pleased me I fed my rooster by
the green apple tree my old rooster went
cock-a-doodle-doo dee doo dee doo dee
doo dee I had a piggy and the piggy
please be I feared by piggy by the green
tree that's better
come on my old brewster when I had a cow
and the cow pleased me I fed my cow by
the green apple tree my old cow
I had a horsie and the horsie pleased me
I fed my horsie by the green apple tree
my horsey when let's try it boys
[Music]
my old piggy when there you go
everybody's saying now my older
[Music]
now that's anything that happened